you're a kid actor anybody in the  industry ever like puts you in an  uncomfortable situation or take  advantage of you like that  well you can't get through this industry  without like  especially I've been a game 35 years and  I started as a kid  thank God I haven't had the worst of it  but I've been around  Darkness  did the darkness touch you it didn't  touch me but it touched the family  member oh and it was horrible it's not  good damn and it was uh I almost wrote  in my book but I'm like it's not really  my story to tell do you go like is this  industry worth it because not only does  it that is it like is somewhere my fame  and whatever I'm doing did that help  cause that oh [ __ ] you know what I'm  saying